all right loser Democrat candidates
getting rewarded for their incompetence
by teaching your kids
oh it took Lori life but I think one
term to run Chicago into the ground and
now she'll be teaching a health policy
and leadership course at Harvard former
San Fran dhsa Boudin he was recalled
he's going to start a new job at UC
Berkeley after voters had enough of his
radical soft on crime policies and
Hillary were crooked as Jesse calls her
will be terrorizing students at Columbia
University two-time loser Stacy Abrams
joining The Faculty of Howard University
uh so Jessica why would anyone want to
send their kids to college when all they
do is shelter failed leftists
I think they do a little bit more than
that and I think that there's something
yeah
I think there's a lot to be learned from
people who have run for office whether
they won or lost people who've had
important jobs whether you think that
they did a great job or not and I just
I've already defended the idea of having
Hillary in that position and how
much it's clear to me that everyone
would want to sign up for that class and
that is what happened but
like five days ago was Henry Kissinger's
100th birthday
all the glowing op-eds about his time is
a man responsible for hundreds of
thousands dead and millions more
negatively impacted If Not Dead from the
actions that he took and people line up
to hear him speak when he when he does
it it doesn't do it as much anymore
because he's 100 years old so I don't
want to hear anything about listening to
Lori Lightfoot or Hillary Clinton or
Chessa Boudin and hopefully they'll be
pushed as well to talk about things that
worked and things that didn't work uh
what didn't work is their policies
especially in the case of Chicago and
San Francisco look at the state those
cities are in now again both of them
might be past the point of no return so
these are academics putting medals on
the chests of bad generals these stupid
ideas came from places like Harvard the
social justice nonsense the harm
reduction policies all the health care
mumbo-jumbo de Blasio and and Laurie and
all these losers they glom onto it
because it makes them sound smart and
compassionate they win on it they enact
these dumb policies and then they fail
and then they lose and so what Harvard
has to do is they have to slap a crimson
Blazer on them so there's not a lot of
failed leftists hanging around with
their hands out
you can't have a bunch of failed
leftists uh sitting around with the
skeletons of all of these dumb academic
policies that failed in the real world
you have to dress it up it's like
academic washing
so what
what going to Columbus you know it's
like why why are people signing up for
that class she's a two-time presidential
loser and Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill
himself well and there are other things
where that came from as well because we
have talked about the Clinton Global
initiative I mean that would be one
thing you could talk about the thing
about dem's losing is that they never go
far right so if you think about better
O'Rourke he ran against Ted Cruz he lost
that Senate race so badly and then his
next step was you know what I think I'm
gonna run for president now and there
was nobody about it and I Chester Boudin
is going to run Cal Berkeley's law
research and Advocacy Center that was
immediately after being recalled and run
out of town then you had Stacy Abrams
she did tremendous damage to her cause
but she had a cause and so she gets to
have the t-shirt and get a big contract
to write a book she just wrote another
novel by the way I suggested that as a
dramatic interpretation for the
exclamation point show I guess my
thoughts boil down to this that Winners
get to make policies and losers go home
except for Democrats they get to go to
Academia where they get sweet paychecks
and brainwasher children but Academia is
home to them you're not seeing Mike
Pence lecturing on what it was like to
be vice president during a pandemic so
it's not fair you could be a failed
leftist and get fired and you get to go
to Harvard I get fired I'm at the
University of Newsmax
but uh again it's just repeating what
you're saying it's a benefit of leftism
it's like even if you were there's
always a lefty Lily Pad waiting for you
even when you're exposed as an
intellectual fraud you know we will if I
lose my job I'd probably end up on some
board of a corporation maybe be a
lobbyist of some kind but they uh oh I
would be a great lobbyist it would be a
terrible idea why would you be good oh
because I would love the product
oh I know what you're lobbying for
eign
okay well you'd make a lot more money on
K Street but Academia
and Academia you don't really have to
work right well can you get speeches the
lobbyists where you're going uh hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else